hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmccontrolac.l2-3.1.9 provide privacy
and security notices consistent with
applicable cui rules
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all of this
cmmc dfars and nist SP 10171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance hero now if I'm going
to jump right into it I'm going to tell
you all right all right all right here
we go all right like my man Mr
McConaughey hey it's time to provide
notice to system users that something is
up here all right the goal of cmmc
control ac.l 2.3.1.9 provide privacy and
security notices consistent with
applicable cui rules it is to alert
users to the idea that the system may
contain cui and activity is likely to be
monitored and recorded and probably is
this is an excellent deterrent and in
some cases maybe a legal mandate
depending upon your local loss so again
anytime we get into recording people
things get a little dicey now
if I was going to assess you there are
two main points I'd be looking for Point
number one determine if privacy and
security notices required by cui
specified rules are identified
consistent and associated with the
specific cui category
that's what I'd be looking for now if I
was giving an answer I would say well
here's an example answer notices are in
place at system startup via Windows
interactive system logon message Group
Policy that's one way you can do it
assessment Point number two determine if
privacy and security notices are
displayed again a sample answer might be
notices are in place at system startup
via Windows interactive system logon
message Group Policy so again you
restart the computer message pops up
says hey there's cui on the machine and
activity is logged and recorded that's a
requirement now other examples may be
physical facility signs okay think door
signs on security sensitive rooms signs
and policy sign in policies like for
visitors
training and more that could be in place
to demonstrate compliance with this
control there's a lot that you can do to
put up the right privacy and security
notices that cuis in the area all right
again we want people to be aware that
there's something going on here that's
security sensitive for sure
and hey
if you need more specific guidance on
that we can definitely help because at
on-call we work with defense contractors
just like you who have had this dfars
nist SP 10171 itar and cmmc compliance
stuff dropped into their laps like a
seagull on a sunny day we teach you how
to level up and be a proper on-call
compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps gray areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance is your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you if you're looking for more
help getting compliant our compliance
experts are always on call for you visit
cmmccomplianceecrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now if you love the content we're
putting out there for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance nerves
nerves roll it out no I'm just kidding
it's me it's not my video editor but
sometimes I like to mess it a little bit
all right until the next compliance tip
my friend stay safe and secure out there
and hit us in the comments comments
below to let us know what you'd like to
know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one one
[Music]
foreign